the next act going into the semifinals
is ten-year-old opera singer fan
favorite Iman beitia is moving on on
America's Got Talent
how does it feel
but Wednesday's results show was tense
and full of surprising eliminations the
night kicked off with somewhat of a
shocker three beloved acts were
announced in the bottom three meaning
one would definitely be going home
comedian Jackie fabulous dog act Lucas
and Falco and guitarist Marcin pachala
Jackie fabulous was ultimately saved by
America's vote what's a piece of advice
do you want to tell people who have a
similar dream like yours
your goal is private don't tell
everybody what you're working on because
the haters want to hear when you're
working on solid advice then the judges
were left to choose between Lucas and
Falco and Marcin Pechaluk I got to go
with something I've never seen before
unique Marcin II I have to go with the
once in a lifetime once in a generation
talent and that is marcin I'm gonna
choose you to go through
this page in particular legendary you
know you say so much on TV I don't think
there's any real way of preparing
yourself to what's going to happen when
you get on it that is being said I
practiced so hard and I was just so
focused on the six streets and they
buddy my guitar we said goodbye to
aerialist Matthew Richardson who
returned to the show as a wild card how
much pressure did you feel coming into
this performance I mean I think it's a
lot of pressure regardless or knowing
that many people are watching but then
to kind of have to prove that you
deserve to come back yeah it's a there's
funky tambourine player gonzo are you
hoping you come back yes of course
while memorable gonzo got cut so ditch
singer mckenzie but our hearts exploded
with joy when we found out this act made
it through going into the semifinals is
I'm feeling amazing it's like a dream
come true honestly it felt electric even
walking off of the stage the energy in
the room was infectious and I loved it
yeah
[Music]